the resistance got a badass
purple-haired new leader in Star Wars
the last Jedi with laura dern joining
the series as vice admiral emmalin hold
oh we're not going to spoil her role for
you here but anyone who's seen the film
knows how important she is and how
stellar Dern was in the part for those
wondering where you've seen her before
here's white Vice Admiral hold Oh looks
so familiar ramblin rose Dern is the
daughter of screen veterans Diane Ladd
and Bruce Dern so she had no trouble
breaking into the business in the 80s
with movies like mask smooth talk wild
at heart and blue velvet Dern really
entered the spotlight though with her
starring role as the title character in
1991's ramblin rose starring opposite
her mother she earned widespread
critical admiration and her first Oscar
nomination Jurassic Park a year after
she broke into the big-time Dern joined
the blockbuster fold by starring in two
big-screen adaptation of Michael
Crichton's Jurassic Park as dr. Ellie
Sadler Jurassic Park ended up being a
huge box-office success and was also a
hit with critics the film spawned two
sequels and Dern had a brief cameo in
Jurassic Park 3 now that the series has
been rebooted with Jurassic world Dern
is hinted that she might be reprising
her old role again sooner than later
citizen Ruth Dern also starred in
Alexander Payne's first notable feature
citizen Ruth as the title character a
poor pregnant woman who becomes a
central figure in the national debate
about abortion Dern said she suspected
that Payne would be the next big thing
when she signed onto citizen Ruth and
her respect for the director maybe part
of why she decided to work with him
again in his 2017 feature downsizing
which arrived in theaters just a week
after the last Jedi October sky Dern's
last role the 20th century came in
1999's October sky a biopic and when she
played the inspirational science teacher
to a group of children who took to
rocketry is a way of escaping their
mining town her character was an
advocate and a source of strength for
the boys throughout and served as one of
the only likable adults in the movie
recount in 2008 Dern helped HBO rehash a
political scandal in the TV movie
recount which followed the controversy
surrounding the 2000 presidential
election in the film Dern plays
Katherine Harris then secretary of state
of Florida where a recount controversy
erupted between
candidates George W Bush and Al Gore
jernt earned her second Golden Globe win
for the part and was also nominated for
an Emmy a SAG Award and more Dern said
she learned a great deal from the
experience of playing such a
controversial real-life figure telling
the Washington Post recount taught me a
lot because my dad told me you can never
hate the characters you play and you
have to love your characters I had to
just figure out how to give some
humanity and depth of passion to a
person that had become a huge stereotype
in this country enlightened her next
small screen role of note was in HBO's
critically acclaimed dramedy series
enlightened on the show Dern played Amy
Jellicoe a woman who after a nervous
breakdown comes back to work with a new
outlook on life
Dern collected another Golden Globe win
and an Emmy nomination for the show and
served as both co-creator and star
however like many critically acclaimed
dramas in the era of peak TV and lighten
never found a big audience and the show
was canceled after just two seasons The
Fault in Our Stars in 2014
turn went back to the mainstream for the
teen oriented romantic comedy The Fault
in Our Stars the movie based on the John
Green novel of the same name featured
Dern as the mother of shailene Woodley's
hazel grace Lancaster a teenager who
falls in love while she deals with
terminal thyroid cancer the film is a
critical success and arrived as a
box-office smash wild it took turn over
20 years to earn another Academy Award
nomination after ramblin rose but her
not for 2014's Wilde was certainly well
deserved Dern starred in the film as the
mother of Reese Witherspoon Cheryl
Strayed who flashes back to her
childhood as she hikes up the Pacific
Crest Trail trying to discover her true
self not only was her performance
celebrated but it wouldn't be the last
buzzy collaboration she'd have with
Witherspoon big little lies HBO's latest
awards season darling big little lies
has earned nods for all of its main
stars at the Emmys the Golden Globes and
more in the series Dern plays Renata
Klein the uptight nemesis of Reese
Witherspoon's madeline mckenzie and Dern
walked away with a Golden Globe
nomination and an Emmy win beating out
her co-star shailene woodley for the
latter award although big little lies
was initially billed as a limited series
it's been renewed for a second season
following overwhelming fandom
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]